hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with the first video
in a sort of a winter series and we're
going to call this the tour of series
basically if you have a suggestion for
something of mine that you want to see a
tour of go ahead and leave it in the
comments down below i'm sure you guys
have a lot of things maybe a tour of a
desktop or a tour of one of my laptops
or
of my desk or something i don't even
know but if you like this series idea go
ahead and give it a thumbs up right
there as the thumbs up button let's uh
see if we can come up with some great
ideas for this series but i figured i'd
keep it simple to start because i don't
have a ton of stuff installed on my
tablet now before you go saying well i
don't have an android tablet this
doesn't help me at all uh you might
learn some things so don't dismiss this
immediately you might learn some things
about how to set up your tablet and
touchpad or fire or ipad whatever you
might have
so this is as you can see my tablet of
choice is the motorola zoom and we are
running honeycomb i'm really excited for
ice cream sandwich whether it's on my
galaxy nexus first or on this tablet
but uh this is my
my lock screen as you can see and the
wallpaper if you want to check that out
will be in the description down below so
one of my favorite wallpapers i have
this on my desktop
and on my tablet
so as you can see i have a couple of
icons lined up just sort of sort of a
tablet friendly mode for my thumbs to be
able to reach them pretty easily google
plus which i do use you can follow me i
have wolfram alpha which is a boss app
google reader music
tweet deck or tweet comb which is a
tablet optimized twitter app i really
enjoy using it and youtube which as you
guys know is pretty much the best video
site you could possibly come up with
ever gotta love youtube and uh the
browser and google currents
so the keyboard i'm using in case you
want to know is the thumb keyboard which
is a sort of a split layout keyboard and
this is the ice cream sandwich theme
so let's go ahead to the right one pane
and you can see i have this very very
minimal pretty simple uh and the
wallpaper really accents that so you can
see i have my weather up here it's
pretty chill day uh less than 40 degrees
so that's pretty nice and down below we
have navigation i actually have used
this for navigation and google calendar
google calendar is awesome i use it to
keep my life organized and it is
a lifesaver i honestly use it all the
time
so this is my nice neat little
helpfulness screen if you will then to
the right is sort of my auxiliary screen
i have some frequently contacted people
and i have my google pages for google
plus and i have all my youtubers on
google plus so if you are a youtuber and
you circle me on google plus i'll see
that so i'll probably circle you back so
i can come up with your stuff and here's
all the google stuff so android youtube
google chrome all those people they are
putting their stuff in here so that's
what i have on the right most home
screen
then we'll go all the way over the left
we have our gmail widget you guys are
blasting me with emails which i really
appreciate because i read all of them
we have our camera in our gallery and i
will open the gallery because this does
change an ice cream sandwich so here's
the honeycomb gallery and all these
pictures are from
google plus mostly and then dropbox
so that's what i have in my gallery and
you can see the wallpaper here is
looking pretty fly
yeah um then we have the gmail widget
which lets me go through all my emails
then i have a blank screen which is
pretty much where i test stuff if you
guys didn't know i do videos for the
droid dog youtube channel and that's
where i can uh test stuff to see how the
widgets work out whether or not it works
out for the tablet or not but that's
basically my tablet this is the motorola
zoom 32 gig wi-fi i don't have a ton of
apps installed so you can see my home
screen layout overview right there
and if you want to see my apps there you
go those are the apps that i have i have
beautiful widgets as you saw before
catalogs uh facebook messenger couple
things i haven't shown you scroll to the
right there's the thumb keyboard
i have a stop watch i have sound hound
infinity
whole bunch of great apps and stuff i
don't keep a ton of stuff on my tablet
because uh to be honest i really like to
keep it on my phone uh and the galaxy
nexus will probably only improve that
but that's basically it guys like i said
if you have a suggestion for another
tour of some sort of gadget let me know
i'd be happy to give you a tour of it
either way this has been mkbhd thanks
for watching and i'll talk to you guys
in the next video
peace
you